ahora veamos si podemos cambiar de
representación decimal la representación
binaria pero de un número un poco más
grande como 114 todos le pausa el vídeo
y trata de escribir 114 en su
representación binaria listo bueno voy a
suponer que por lo menos existe un muy
buen intento y vamos a trabajarlo juntos
una vez más vamos a necesitar las
potencias de 2 así es que vamos a
escribirlas por aquí tenemos 2 a la 0
que es igual a 1 2 a la 1 que es igual a
2 2 a la 2 que es 4 2 a la 38 2 a la 4
16 2 a las 5 30 y 22 a las 6
64 2 a las 7 128 y listo ya no
necesitamos ninguna otra potencia de 2
porque 128 ya es más grande que 114
entonces vamos a escribir a 114 como la
suma de puras potencias de 2 entonces
empezamos buscando la potencia de 2 más
grande que quepa dentro de 114 entonces
128 no cabe dentro de 114 seguimos
buscando 64 si cabe dentro de 114 así es
que este es el primer elemento que vamos
a sumar por aquí
ahora tenemos que escribir a 114 como la
suma de 64 y otra cosa y bueno para que
nos quede 114 a 64 a 64 le tenemos que
sumar
50 ahora 50 no es una potencia de 2 pero
si se puede escribir como una suma de
potencias de 2 y eso es justo lo que
vamos a hacer entonces 50 lo podemos
escribir como a ver cuál es la potencia
de 2 más grande que cabe dentro de 50
pues el 32 si cabe dentro del 50 no
entonces vamos a escribir a este 50 como
32 más 18 entonces vamos a escribirlo
como la suma de algunas potencias de 2
cuál es la potencia de 2 más grande que
cabe dentro de 18 pues esa es este
número de aquí que es 16 entonces
escribimos a 18 como 16 más 2
a 2 el 2 si es una potencia de 2 muy
bien entonces ya tenemos a 114 escrito
como una suma de potencias de 2 114 es
igual a 64 más 32 32 más 16
16 más 2
2 ya escribimos a 114 como sumas de
potencias de 2 que bueno podríamos
escribirlo como en el vídeo pasado como
la suma de un 64 más un 32 más un 16 más
12 y luego irnos al mundo del sistema
binario y empezar a poner los lugares de
las cifras empezamos por la primera
cifra que es el lugar de los 12 después
inmediatamente a la izquierda está el
lugar de los 12
luego tenemos el lugar de los cuatros
recuerda que vamos multiplicando de dos
en dos conforme vamos pasando del lugar
a la izquierda
así es que llegamos al lugar de los
hechos y después llegamos al lugar de
los 16 es a la izquierda está el lugar
de los 32 es y luego el lugar de los 64
y podríamos seguir nos multiplicando por
2 hacia la izquierda todo lo que
quisiéramos pero aquí están todos los
lugares que necesitamos aunque y
empezamos en la suma de potencias de 2
que nos da 114 cuántos unos tenemos pues
tenemos 0 unos cuantos 12 tenemos pues
tenemos 12 ok en cada uno de estos
lugares siempre tenemos o 0 o 1 porque
son los únicos dígitos del sistema
binario y es muy fácil ponemos 0 si no
tenemos que sumar ningún 1 o ponemos 1
si si tenemos que sumar al 2
ahora vamos al lugar que nos dice
cuántos cuatro tenemos que sumar y pues
vemos que no hay ningún cuatro en esta
suma entonces tenemos que poner cero no
hay ni un solo 8 aquí entonces ponemos 0
luego buscamos si hay un 16 y si aquí
está el 16 así es que ponemos un 1
también hay un 32 entonces aquí va un 1
y también hay un 64 entonces aquí
también va un 1 y hemos terminado
si queremos escribir al número decimal
114 en representación binaria tenemos
que escribir 1 1 1 0 0 1 0 y listo